so jetzt geht's aber los mit der ersten
Lesung zur Änderung des Atomgesetzes die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel bas hat
jetzt diesen Tagesordnungspunkt
aufgerufen Naturschutz nukleare
Sicherheit und Verbraucherschutz Steffi
Lemm und erste Rednerin die
bundesumweltministerinnen für nukleare
Sicherheit ist ihr auch zuständig Steffi
Lemke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir beraten
heute die 19 Änderung des Atomgesetzes
und ich muss eingangs ganz klar sagen
mir wäre es lieber wenn diese Änderung
des Atomgesetzes nicht erforderlich wäre
Deutschland hat sich aus sehr guten
Gründen entschlossen aus der Atomkraft
auszusteigen und heute beraten wir
darüber dass wir den Atomausstieg
angesichts der sehr schwierigen Lage auf
dem Energiemarkt um dreieinhalb Monate
nach hinten verschieben wir sehen uns
dazu gezwungen weil Russland in seinem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine versucht mit seiner fossilen
Erpressung die Unterstützung des
demokratischen Europa für die
ukrainischen für den ukrainischen
Freiheitskampf zu schwächen und weil das
Abwürgen der Energiewende und der
verhängnisvolle Pakt mit dem billigen
Gas in 16 Jahren unionsgeführter
Bundesregierungen zu dieser fossilen
Erpressbarkeit geführt haben
ich sage dazu ganz klar wir lassen uns
nicht erpressen und Atomkraft kann jetzt
einen Beitrag dazu liefern besser über
den jetzt anstehenden Winter zu kommen
einen kleinen Beitrag nicht mehr nicht
weniger
gleichwohl wäre es absolut fahrlässig in
dieser Situation auf diesem Beitrag
leichtfertig zu verzichten und mit dem
vorliegende 19 Gesetz zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes dürfen drei Atomkraftwerke
in Deutschland über den
31.12.2022 hinaus bis
spätestens zum 15 April 2023
Elektrizität erzeugen
meine Damen und Herren der Ihnen
vorliegende Gesetzentwurf Nacht
andererseits aber auch absolut deutlich
es muss beim Atomausstieg bleiben
Atomenergie ist und bleibt gefährlich
und ja nichts ist ohne Risiko aber bei
Atomkraft werden die Folgen eines
Unfalls oder gar eines Angriffs so
unglaublich verheerend dass wir gerade
jetzt daraus müssen der Deutsche
Bundestag hat 2011 abgewogen und
beschlossen dass dieses Restrisiko der
Atomkraftnutzung noch bis zum
31.12.2022 vertretbar ist das waren eine
Bundesregierung geführt von cdu/csu und
FDP und die nötige Abwägung zwischen
Versorgungssicherheit der Bevölkerung
mit Energie und den Risiken für den
Schutz der körperlichen Unversehrtheit
unserer Bevölkerung ist gerade im
Vergleich zu diesem Ausstiegsbeschluss
von 2011 jetzt eigentlich viel klarer
Atomkraftwerke sind erstmals im Jahr
2022 zum Ziel eines Krieges geworden sie
werden beschossen sie werden besetzt sie
werden vom Stromnetz gekappt und wir
erleben Angriffe und Sabotageakte auf
die Energieinfrastruktur in Europa und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
deshalb ist es natürlich absolut richtig
dass die Bundesregierung dass die
Koalition in ihrer Abwägung zu dem
Ergebnis kommt dass wir zwar drei
Kraftwerke noch einige Wochen länger
laufen lassen um möglichst sicher durch
den Winter zu kommen das aber vor allem
mit dieser Gesetzesnovelle klargestellt
wird dass es beim Atomausstieg in
Deutschland bleibt Punkt
und um das vorwegzunehmen es wäre
natürlich aus den genannten Gründen
absolut falsch die AKW einfach
weiterlaufen zu lassen auch nur über den
Winter 23 24 hinaus ein preisdämpfender
Aspekt bei einer Laufzeitverlängerung
wäre wenn überhaupt absolut überschaubar
bereits die technische Realisierbarkeit
zweifelhaft Fragen der Sicherheit ohne
sicherheitsrabatt kaum zu beantworten
grundlegende Aspekte der Haftung
grundlegende Aspekte der Rolle des
Staates müssten neu verhandelt werden
und nicht zuletzt haben die Betreiber
ihres Skepsis mehrfach zu Protokoll
gegeben
und deshalb meine Damen und Herren von
der cdu/csu ihr werben für eine echte
Laufzeitverlängerung es wäre
glaubwürdiger wenn Sie nicht bereits vor
dem Beginn des Angriffskrieges Russlands
gegen die Ukraine genau diese Debatte
begonnen hätten vor dem Angriffskrieg
mit ihren atomträumen mit ihren
atomträumen Versuchen sie tatsächlich
eine Entscheidung die sie unter der von
Frau Merkel geführten Bundesregierung
getroffen haben und Teile von ihnen nie
verschmerzt haben jetzt in dieser
Situation wo unser Land vor einer Krise
steht vor einer potenziellen Krise steht
in dieser Situation diese Debatte jetzt
erneut anzuheizen nachdem sie uns
unserem Land und der Sicherheit in
unserem Land mit ihrer damaligen Abkehr
vom Atomausstieg und wenige Monate
später dem Ausstieg vom Ausstieg ein
Bärendienst erwiesen haben diesen
Schmerz jetzt noch zu verarbeiten in
dieser Krise ich halte das für
verantwortungslos
die Abhängigkeit Europas und der
gesamten Welt von russischem und
kasachischem uran ist nicht minder
ausgeprägt als die von Gas von der
Abhängigkeit russischer Atomtechnologie
ganz zu schweigen und wir sehen mit
Bedauern wie unsere osteuropäischen
Nachbarn versuchen müssen sich aus dem
Klammergriff von rossertum zu entwinden
und das ist Gründe hat dass die nukleare
Versorgung immer noch nicht vom
europäischen Sanktionsregime erfasst ist
all diese Gründe führen dazu die
Endlagerfrage kommt noch dazu dass wir
Generationen unserer Kinder Enkel
Ururenkel den Atommüll überlassen bisher
weltweit kein einziges Endlager in
Betrieb befindlich ist all diese
Probleme all diese völlig ungelösten
Fragen und vor allem eine notwendige
neue Sicherheitsbewertung von Atomkraft
nach dem Angriffskrieg Russlands der
Atomkraftwerke in der Ukraine mit
erfasst hast führen dazu wir bleiben
beim Atomausstieg atomkraft ist nicht
die Zukunft sondern die Vergangenheit
und deshalb bitte ich Sie um Zustimmung
zu diesem Gesetzentwurf vielen Dank
sagt Steffi Lemke ja die Grünen Minister
Steffi Lemke und Robert Habeck hatten
noch im März davon abgeraten die drei
ackerwes länger als geplant zu betreiben
dann hatte Robert Haag vorgeschlagen
eine
Reservebetrieb für die beiden
süddeutschen AKWs und dann gab es wegen
unterschiedliche Ansichten in der Ampel
eine Machtwort von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz deswegen heute dieser
Gesetzentwurf sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin mit ihrer Politik verspielen
sie das Vertrauen der Menschen in
unserem Land und das Thema Kernenergie
macht das ganz besonders deutlich warum
sage ich das dazu drei Punkte dazu drei
Punkte 1
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat zu Beginn
des Krieges gegen die Ukraine eine
ergebnisoffene Prüfung der Nutzung der
Kernenergie versprochen
die mehr von einer ergebnisoffenen und
ideologiefreien Prüfung nimmt Ihnen
spätestens nach den letzten Enthüllungen
keiner mehr ab Frau Ministerin
Frau Lemke und der Habeck hatten nie vor
das Potenzial unserer Kernkraftwerke in
einer Gesamtstrategie jetzt in der Krise
ja ich sage ganz bewusst jetzt in der
Krise für eine sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung unseres Landes
wirklich mit einzubeziehen die Aspekte
was es am besten für unser Klima was ist
am besten für die Strompreisentwicklung
waren doch gar nicht wirklich Teil
dieser Prüfung sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin das geht so nicht aus meiner
Sicht wäre eine Entschuldigung bei den
Menschen in unserem Land jetzt
angebracht
zweiter Punkt sie negieren weiterhin
hartnäckig die möglichen preisdämpfenden
Effekte einer weiterreichenden einer
weiterreichenden nicht nur dreieinhalb
Monate Laufzeit verringern Verlängerung
Frau Professor Veronika Grimm andere
Ökonomen auch der Energiekonzern EnBW
der von einem grün geführten von einer
grün geführten Landesregierung
kontrolliert wird sagen es eindeutig für
2024 ließe sich der Strompreis unter
bestimmten Voraussetzungen um bis zu 12
13 Prozent senken die Experten sagen wir
brauchen dringend auch
2023 und 2024 ein breiteres
Energieangebot um die Preissteigerungen
beim Strom zu dämpfen und die 0,8
Prozent
hervorsitzender des Umweltausschusses
die Fohlen genannt wurden von den
Experten die beziehen sich nur auf die
dreieinhalb Monate ich rede von den zwei
Jahren die wir vorschlagen Frau Dr
Weißgerber gestatten sie eine
Zwischenbemerkung oder Zwischenfrage aus
der Fraktion DIE LINKE ich würde jetzt
gerne weiterfahren
mit einem streckbetrieb der drei derzeit
noch laufenden Kernkraftwerke für nur
dreieinhalb Monate erreichen sie
letztendlich viel zu wenig wir brauchen
stattdessen einen Weiterbetrieb bis
mindestens Ende 24 so wie wir es
vorschlagen und natürlich frische
Brennelemente vor allem KEF Frau
Ministerin sie sind
Verbraucherschutzministerin warum lassen
sie die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
so im Regen stehen und nehmen diesen
einfachen preisdämpfungseffekt für die
kommenden Jahre nicht mit sie tun nicht
das was jetzt in der Krise ich betone
jetzt in der Krise es ist kein Ausstieg
aus dem Ausstieg sieht betonen nicht das
was jetzt in der Krise angezeigt ist und
verspielen noch mehr Vertrauen das ist
nicht das was unser Land jetzt braucht
frau Ministerin
dritter Punkt mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf
suggerieren sie dass die Energiekrise
die stromkrise im April nächsten Jahres
beendet sein wird schön wärs aber mit
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit wird das
genauso eben nicht kommen und es ist
eine Irreführung der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wenn Herr Kubicki das geht an die
Adresse der FDP sagt dass er sich sicher
sei dass wir im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres
das Thema Kernenergie neu diskutieren
werden denn im Unterschied zum
streckbetrieb brauchen wir dann Ende
April 24 eben neue Brennelemente ohne
neue Brennelemente wird es im nächsten
Jahr einfach nicht weitergehend 23 und
wenn wir jetzt keine neuen Brennelemente
bestellen verschenken wir weitere sechs
Monate das heißt im Klartext
so wie sie das Gesetz jetzt konzipiert
haben ist das Thema Kernenergie im April
23 durch und zwar egal ob wir egal ob
wir im nächsten Jahr Engpässe haben oder
nicht das ist Murks meine Damen und
Herren das ist Politik ohne Weitsicht
was wäre die Lösung ganz einfach eine
Überprüfungsklausel um im Laufe des
nächsten Jahres zu entscheiden welche
kernkraftwerkskapazitäten angesichts der
versorgensicherheit und der
Strompreisentwicklung benötigt werden
haben sie dazu in ihrem Gesetzentwurf
ein entsprechende Klausel vorgesehen
sehr geehrte Kollegen von Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der FDP natürlich nicht
unser Gesetzentwurf sieht eine solche
Überprüfungsklausel vor am Freitag haben
Sie die Chance diesem Gesetzentwurf
zuzustimmen ich fordere Sie auf beginnen
sie endlich mit einer pragmatischen der
Krise angemessenen und vor allen Dingen
weitsichtigen Politik unser Land braucht
weniger Ideologie und mehr
Verantwortungsbewusstsein nur so können
wir das Vertrauen der Menschen
zurückgewinnen vielen Dank
und in dem von hier Anja Weißgerber
vorgeschlagen
der
cdu/csu-fraktion da fordert die Fraktion
nämlich eine Laufzeitverlängerung ist
mindestens 31 dezember
2024 über diesen Gesetzentwurf der wird
übrigens auch am Freitag abgestimmt
Jakob Blankenburg können wir jetzt für
die SPD frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir beraten
hier jetzt heute in erster Lesung über
den von der Ampelkoalition vorgelegten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes dieser sieht vor dass die
drei Atomkraftwerke über zwei in der
kawestheim 2 und Emsland erst am 15
April 2023 und nicht wie ursprünglich
geplant Ende dieses Jahres vom Netz
gehen die Koalition aus SPD grün und FDP
strebt also an Atomkraftwerke
dreieinhalb Monate länger am Netz zu
lassen als ursprünglich geplant ein
durchaus bemerkenswerter Schritt ein
Schritt der vor einem Jahr für mich als
frisch gewählte Abgeordneter unter
anderem für das Wendland die Keimzelle
des anti-akkw-protest in Deutschland
vollkommen unverständlich gewesen wäre
zu lange musste im Wendland und in
vielen anderen Ecken Deutschlands auf
der Straße für den Atomausstieg gekämpft
werden genauso wie hier im Bundestag vor
allen Dingen auf der linken Seite des
Hauses heute da stehe ich vor Ihnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und sage
es ist richtig dass wir die Änderung des
Atomgesetzes auf den Weg bringen die
Situation im November 2022 unterscheidet
sich fundamental von der im November
2021 wir leben in Zeiten eines
abscheulichen angriffskriegs Russlands
auf die Ukraine Russland führt diesen
Krieg auf ukrainischen Boden gegen das
ukrainische Volk und Russland führt ein
Energie-
die Unterbrechung der russischen
Erdgaslieferungen kommen zusammen mit
einem unzureichenden Ausbau der
Windkraft und der Stromnetze gerade in
Süddeutschland wir haben es in den
Zwischenrufen dann eben gerade zu Recht
gehört und dem Ausfall eines
substanziellen Anteils der französischen
Kernkraftwerke
das hat die Lage auf den Energiemärkten
weiter verschärft diese angespannte
energieversorgungssituation ist der
Grund warum wir hier heute die Änderung
des Atomgesetzes diskutieren
der Stresstest der viel
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber hat gezeigt
dass wir im kommenden Winter im
schlimmsten ich wiederhole im
schlimmsten Szenario temporäre regionale
Stromausfälle und keine Blackouts wie
immer wieder von dieser Seite des Hauses
glauben gemacht werden würde in
Deutschland nicht komplett ausschließen
können und das trotz der zahlreichen
Maßnahmen die bereits durch die
Bundesregierung getroffen wurden und
deshalb gehen wir nun diesen Schritt
jetzt weiter Betriebs der drei noch am
Netz befindlichen Atomkraftwerke für die
kommenden Wintermonate was der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und mir besonders
dabei wichtig war dieser Weiterbetrieb
erfolgt als streikbetrieb es werden
keine neuen Brennstäbe gekauft
stattdessen
stattdessen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen werden die bereits in den AKW
genutzten Brennstäbe so neu konfiguriert
dass sie noch für einen etwas längeren
Zeitraum energieliefern können wir
schöpfen die bereits bestehenden
Energiequellen also voll aus das ist das
was wir in der besonders angespannten
Energiesituation braucht
was wir mit dem Gesetzentwurf nicht tun
ist das was sie was die Opposition
fordert und was ja auch koalitionsintern
in den letzten Monaten intensiv
diskutiert wurde wir kündigen den
Atomausstieg nicht auf
hier wir halten fest liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen worum jahrzehntelang
gerungen wurde und was 2011 in diesem
Hohen Hause mit sehr breiter Mehrheit
beschlossen wurde übrigens auch aus
ihrer Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Weißgerber dem Ende der
hochrisikotechnologie Atomkraft das ist
wichtig denn das was 2011 galt gilt auch
heute 11 Jahre später Punkt eins
Atomkraft ist für den Menschen nicht
beherrschbar und bringt gewaltige
Sicherheitsrisiken das haben wir 1986 in
Tschernobyl erlebt 2011 in Fukushima und
auch jetzt im Jahr 2022 mit den
gezielten Angriffen auf ukrainische
Atomkraftwerke wie das in saporizia
menschliches Versagen Naturkatastrophen
kriegerische Angriffe sie alle können zu
nuklearen Zwischenfällen von gewaltigem
Ausmaß führen und damit Menschenleben
zerstören und die Natur für Jahrzehnte
oder Jahrhunderte unwirtlich machen und
selbst wenn die Nutzung der Atomenergie
ohne Störfälle gelingt dann bleibt immer
noch Punkt 2 die Frage der sicheren
Endlagerung der hochradioaktiven
Hinterlassenschaften der der Atomenergie
die es weiter ungeklärt jeden Tag den
wir die Atomenergie weiter nutzen
produzieren wir mehr Abfälle von denen
wir heute nicht wissen wohin und das ist
eine gewaltige Bürde für die
nachkommenden Generation und
und
damit komme ich zu Punkt 3 Atomenergie
ist teuer und das auch wenn Sie uns das
als Vertreter in der Opposition immer
wieder etwas anderes glauben machen
wollen wir haben es eben gerade in der
fachanhörung in der in der Anhörung im
Umweltausschuss gehört Atomenergie ist
die teuerste der Energieform es ist
deutlich teurer als Strom aus den
erneuerbaren und allein die zwischen-
und Endlagerung das müssen Sie sich
bewusst machen allein die zwischen- und
Endlagerung der radioaktiven Abfälle
verschlingt mehr als eine Milliarde Euro
jedes
diese Punkte die haben wir 2011 die
haben 2011 den Ausschlag für die
politische Entscheidung gegen die
weitere Nutzung der Atomenergie gegeben
und mit dieser Entscheidung da wurde ein
gesellschaftlicher Konflikt befriedet
und es wurde die Basis für ein
strukturiertes Verfahren der
Endlagersuche geschaffen und an diesem
im Standortauswahlgesetz festgelegten
Verfahren da müssen wir weiter
festhalten statt immer wiederkehrende
Debatten um eine Renaissance der
Atomkraft Zweifel an der Glaubwürdigkeit
des atomenergies zu nähren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie uns einen Schlussstrich unter diese
Debatte ziehen genau das machen wir mit
dieser Änderung des Atomgesetzes sie
lenkt von den wirklich wichtigen Fragen
ab wir müssen jetzt unter Hochdruck am
Umbau unserer Energieversorgung hin zu
Unabhängigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit
arbeiten und Atomenergie ist dafür
definitiv nicht die Lösung wir brauchen
wir brauchen stattdessen mehr Strom und
Wärme aus erneuerbaren und wir brauchen
Übertragungsnetze damit der Strom auch
dahin gelangt wo er gebraucht wird
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
dass diese Vorhaben gelingen statt Zeit
mit der Debatten der Vergangenheit zu
verschwenden vielen Dank
Jakob Blankenburg war das er ist direkt
gewählte Abgeordneter im Wahlkreis für
Lüchow-Dannenberg der ja über Jahrzehnte
geprägt war durch Proteste gegen dass
ich ehemals potenzielle geplante
atommüllentslager Gorleben
reiner Kraft jetzt für die AFD
ja sehr geehrte Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen im Ergebnis einer Abwägung von
Nutzen und Risiken ist eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei noch
bestehenden Atomkraftwerke auch
angesichts der aktuellen Gaskrise nicht
zu empfehlen Zitat Ende so argumentiert
das bmvo in seinem Prüfvermerk vom März
und selten lag eine Einschätzung so weit
neben der Realität wie diese
Offenbarungseid aus dem Hause von
Ministerin landte
obwohl also der jetzige Gesetzesentwurf
in Sachen der drei weiterlaufenden
Kernkraftwerke das bmuv fachlich
komplett vorführt so ist er dennoch
energiepolitisch vollkommen unzureichend
um der energienotlage in der Sie dieses
Land befindet gerecht zu werden zu wenig
und zu spät das fast sehr gut das
bisherige Krisenmanagement der
Bundesregierung zusammen nur
scheibchenweise und unter enormem Druck
der Bürger und Unternehmen die am Ende
die Zeche der energiepolitischen
Inkompetenz der Regierung zu zahlen
haben werden ist diese Regierung des
Aussetzens gewillt die notwendigen
Realitäten ins Auge zu schauen
erstens dieses Land hat eine
Energieproblem und es ist nicht die
fragestrom oder Gas wie ist der Herr
Minister schon öfter gesagt hat es ist
sowohl Strom und Gas das uns fehlt und
am Thema Strom zweitens müssen wir das
tun Strom und Gas werden jetzt benötigt
das ist zweitens werden jetzt benötigt
doch Maßnahmen die kurzfristig wirken
und nicht in einer fernen irgendwann
absehbaren Zukunft Ankündigungen zum
verstärkten Ausbau und zuverlässiger
Wind und Solarenergie sowie die Absicht
irgendwann irgendwas mit vielleicht
masterstoff zu machen sind bestenfalls
Nebelkerzen in der entscheidenden Frage
wie wir durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommen werden viel
wahrscheinlicher ist es allerdings dass
wir hier bei Ressourcen verschwenden die
wir dann in diesen beiden Bildern
dringend benötigt hätten
und eine dieser verschwindeten
Ressourcen das sind die drei noch
laufenden Kernkraftwerke und sowohl die
Union als auch die AFD haben vollkommen
richtige Gesetzesentwürfe präsentiert
die sie noch mindestens zwei Jahre unter
Volllast eine Energieerzeugung in
Deutschland zu beteiligen voll
abgeschriebene Kraftwerke mit
geschätzten Gestehungskosten so um die 3
Cent die Kilowattstunde
und der Entwurf der Bundesregierung weil
sie gerade sagen Atome wir hatten gerade
die Anhörung sie waren ja lange nicht da
um diesen halbe bis eine Prozent mehr
kommt es am Ende überhaupt nicht drauf
an ja es kommt auf dieses Prozent nicht
mehr an denn Wurf der Bundesregierung
will nun diese vier Gigawatt an
zuverlässiger Leistung in die Reserve
verbannen und hofft gleichzeitig auf
gutes Wetter und einen warmen Winter
damit wir gut durch den Winter kommen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen die
Verlierer
die Verlierer dieses bossenspiels stehen
auch schon fest es sind die Stromkunden
und Steuerzahler um vier Prozent
mindestens könnte der Strompreis sinken
wenn die Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
würden so dass renommierte Ifo-Institut
höre 20 genannt worden von der Kollegin
her aber recheren diese Bundesregierung
schon vier Prozent niedrige Stromkosten
ja es ist ja nur Geld das Geld der
Wähler und Steuerzahler das ist Ihnen
doch komplett egal aber dafür dass
deutsche Familien vier Prozent weniger
beim Strom bezahlen da tritt kein grüner
Minister vor seine Leute vor seine
Parteimitglieder und räumt eine diese
grünen Lebenslügen Weg für vier Prozent
niedrige Stromkosten für kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen stellt sich kein
FDP-Minister hin und was ich dir auf
seine Privilegien oder beendet diese
irrlichternden geisterfahrerkoalition
und vier Prozent reduzierte Stromkosten
sind auch bei der SPD nichts um die SPD
aus ihrem Flecken aufzuwachen hauptsache
die Koalition hält bis 2025 und wenn man
dazu in der Frage der Kernkraft die
Wähler allen voran diejenigen diejenigen
Niedersachsen anlügen muss komplett
anlügen muss komplett egal
dass die Koalition in dieser Frage
falsch liegt zeigt ein Blick in die
Nachbarländer ja kennen die gefeiert
Renaissance allen Unkenrufen zum Trotz
polen will einsteigen Frankreich und
Schweden verkündet den bauernheuer
Kraftwerke Belgien verschiebt erneut den
Ausstieg die Liste der Nutzer ist lang
und alle haben sie etwas gemeinsam sie
sorgen für preiswerte und zuverlässige
Stromversorgung ihrer Länder und damit
machen diese Länder Energie sich
energiezuberennen und Koppeln sich auch
von auch von den unzuverlässigen
Stromversorgung Deutschlands ab und weil
diese Länder in Zukunft Strom
zuverlässig haben werden sie dann auch
mit sattem Gewinn in Deutschland mit
Strom versorgen können und dazu sage ich
Gott sei Dank denn hier regiert eine mit
dem Thema Energieversorgung komplett
überfordert die Bundesregierung die eben
das nicht kann
nächste Rednerin für die FDP-Fraktion
Carina Konrad und sie ist die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jede
Kilowattstunde zählt mit diesem
Botschaft mit diesem Appell hat sich der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister im Juni an die
Menschen gewarnt und dieser
einsparappell der ist auch bis heute
richtig jeder Beitrag zur Bewältigung
der Krise macht einen Unterschied der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine ist auch zu einem
energiekrieg geworden gegen Europa und
er hat uns auch besonders stark
getroffen erhöht das Fundament auf auf
dass wir alle gebaut haben in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten und diese
Sabotage von Frieden von Freiheit und
von Wohlstand die darf Putin nicht
gelingen und wir kämpfen hier Tag für
Tag dafür damit sie putinisch gelingt
haben wir wirklich schon alles getan
diese Frage stelle ich mir jeden Tag neu
und die Menschen überprüfen sich auch
alle jeden Tag sie sparen Energie und
leisten entscheidende Beiträge das ist
anstrengend das ist auch unbequem ich
habe mit einer Familie gesprochen die
haben den ganzen Oktober nicht geheizt
bei uns im Mittelgebirge in
Rheinland-Pfalz war das schon manchmal
nachts ganz schön kalt so ein Verzicht
der ist unbequem aber er ist machbar und
tagtäglich senden aber Unternehmen
unterschiedlichster Branchen jetzt
Notrufe an uns Stellenabbau
Produktionseinschränkungen
produktionsabbau sogar die Standortfrage
wird immer öfter offen gestellt Menschen
und Unternehmen sind angesichts der
enormen finanziellen Herausforderungen
überlastet diese Krise geht an unsere
Substanz und wir tragen als Parlament
die Verantwortung dafür in dieser
schwierigen Zeit die richtigen Antworten
zu finden und das tun wir wir können
entlassen und das haben wir mit drei
entlastungspaketen getan doch wir können
diese Krise nicht Komplex
subventionieren das funktioniert nicht
wir müssen auch die Energieversorgung
sichern eine sichere eine saubere und
eine bezahlbare Versorgung mit Energie
ist überlebensnotwendig für Menschen und
für Wirtschaft in unserem Land und dafür
ändern wir in dieser Woche auch das
Atomgesetz das ist eine Frage der
Vernunft diese Entscheidung ist
unumgänglich geworden und mit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei sicheren
und der dreiklimaneutralen
Kernkraftwerke Isa 2 Emsland und
Neckarwestheim 2 wird die
Stromversorgung über den Winter
stabilisiert und natürlich war der Weg
bis hierhin nicht einfach wer hätte denn
ernsthaft im letzten Jahr gedacht dass
es eine Ampel ist die die
Laufzeitverlängerung von drei
Kernkraftwerken beschließt und ich bin
dankbar dass unsere Koalitionspartner
diesen Weg mit uns gehen und ich bin
auch Olaf Scholz dankbar für seinen Mut
den Menschen in unserem Land mit seiner
Entscheidung Stabilität zu geben denn
wir haben nicht nur einen stresste bei
den Kraftwerken durchgeführt machen wir
uns ehrlich der energiestresstest wurde
in diesem wurde für diesen Winter
durchgeführt und er hat gezeigt dass uns
Netz Engpässe und schwierige
versorgungssituationen bevorstehen
können um das zu verhindern ist diese
Entscheidung diese Laufzeitverlängerung
richtig doch diese Krise ist auch ein
Stresstest für unsere Gesellschaft viele
Menschen müssen die Komfortzone
verlassen und die erwarten zu Recht dass
auch die Politik alle notwendigen
Entscheidungen trifft um das
Energieangebot zu sichern und
auszudehnen und die Reaktionen übrigens
bei Gas- und Strompreisen aktuell zeigen
uns dass wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind
mit den Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen und
das ist ein zentrales Signal zu
Entspannung und auch deshalb ist diese
Entscheidung die wir heute treffen
richtig und auch Europa
stresst diese Energiekrise wir sind
eingebunden in den europäischen
Energiemarkt und da hilft man sich
gegenseitig und da ist man auch
voneinander abhängig und jedes Land muss
deshalb auch seinen Beitrag dazu leisten
Energie zu sichern und Netze zu
entlasten und auch deshalb ist diese
Laufzeitverlängerung richtig und mit der
Verlängerung dieser Laufzeiten
entspannen wir die Energie Situation für
diesen Winter wir entlasten die
angespannte Gesellschaft und wir
entspannen auch unsere Beziehungen zu
den europäischen Nachbarn doch nach
diesem Winter und da haben sie ja recht
kommt garantiert wieder ein Winter und
man muss kein Prophet sein um auch heute
schon sagen zu können dass die Frage der
Energieversorgung auch dann zentral sein
muss und deshalb müssen auch heute schon
alle notwendigen Maßnahmen eingeleitet
werden und über den nächsten Winter
hinaus die richtigen Antworten zu geben
und ich kann Ihnen für die FDP-Fraktion
versprechen dass wir dabei weiter
genauso konstruktiv wie bisher aber auch
genauso deutlich sein werden wie sehr
ein nachhaltiger Wohlstandsverlust und
eine nachhaltige Destabilisierung
unserer wirtschaftlichen Grundlage und
unseres Zusammenlebens in Sicherheit und
Freiheit steht auf dem Spiel und das ist
genau das Ziel was Putin doch verfolgt
und dieses Ziel darf er nicht erreichen
und wir Freien Demokraten wir werden
nicht
zulassen
und wird wir müssen diesen Stresstest
hier wohl oder übel gemeinsam bestehen
und dafür werden wir gemeinsam
miteinander ringen und wir werden auch
weiter streiten doch am Ende müssen
Entscheidungen getroffen werden denn
unsere Aufgabe ist es Frieden Freiheit
und Wohlstand zu beschützen und das
heute und auch für die Zukunft unser
gesellschaftliches und unser
wirtschaftliches Fundament ist auf eine
sichere auf eine saubere und auch auf
eine bezahlbare Energieversorgung gebaut
und dieses Fundament braucht Stabilität
und dafür zählt jede Kilowattstunde und
deshalb bitte ich um breite Zustimmung
in dieser Woche zu diesem Gesetz vielen
Dank gesagt Carina Konrad für die FDP
auch wenn Ihre Fraktion sich hätte noch
längere Laufzeiten vorstellen können und
eine zentrale Forderung der FDP war ja
ursprünglich auch die Beschaffung neuer
Brennstäbe das soll es aber nach diesem
hier gelesenen Gesetz nicht geben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe zuhören
Zuhörer letzte Woche trat in Frankreich
aus dem Leck eines Reaktors
Radioaktivität aus zum Glück gibt die
Radioaktivität im Reaktorgebäude dieser
Reaktor ist 34 Jahre alt und schon
versagt das Material
wer denkt dies wäre ein Einzelfall den
muss ich enttäuschen in Frankreich sind
zurzeit etwa die Hälfte der 56
Atomreaktoren wegen ähnlichen
Materialproblemen außer Betrieb
die deutschen Atomkraftwerke haben das
gleiche Alter
seit Monaten weise ich Sie auf die
Probleme mit Atomkraftwerken hin lege
ihn die realen Gefahren von
Atomkraftwerken dar das können Sie in
mein Reden nachverfolgen aber sie die
atomkraft-lobby ist in der Ampel der
Union und der AFD blenden die unangenehm
Wahrheit zu Atomkraft aus und dies würde
zu jeder Abwägung gehören müssen
ihre Hauptbegründung für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung ist
Energieknappheit in diesem Winter im
Frühjahr sah es auch danach aus aber
durch die wieder in Betriebnahme von
Kohlekraftwerken im Herbst ist die
Energieversorgung technisch
sichergestellt
um eines klarzustellen ist ärgert mich
das vorübergehend Kohlekraftwerke wieder
laufen müssen aber in dieser Situation
ist mir Kohlestrom lieber als mit den
riesigen der Atomkraft leben zu müssen
die Koalition begründet ihre
Entscheidung mit dem Stresstest der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber aber wir haben
kein erzeugungsproblem in der
Stromversorgung sondern ein politisches
Problem
künstlicher Wettbewerb mit
sternregularien und Börsenspekulationen
drängen uns den Atomstrom auf bin ich
wiederhole es bewusst noch einmal wir
brauchen keinen Atomstrom um durch den
Winter zu kommen es wäre eigentlich ganz
einfach
teilen Sie Deutschland in zwei
stromhandelspreiszonen dann dürfen die
süddeutschen Kraftwerke ständig Strom
liefern auch bei viel Windkraft im
Norden werden sie dann nicht aus
regulatorischen Gründen abgeschaltet um
es Ihnen noch mal klar zu erläutern die
Mangellage in Deutschland besteht nicht
wenn wenig Wind liegt weht die mangelage
besteht wenn in Norddeutschland viel
Wind ist und dann natürlich der Strom
nicht nach Bayern geliefert werden kann
und in Bayern aber wegen des zu vielen
Windstroms im Norden Gas und Kohle
Handwerker abgeschaltet werden solch
einen Schwachsinn zu an solch einem
Schwachsinn fest zu halten ist falsch
und dann die Atomkraftwerke als Ersatz
in die Waagschale zu werfen ist der
völlig falsche Weg und das lehnen wir
als LINKE ab und im übrigen wenn Sie
diesen Vorschlag der Strompreis der
stromhandelszonentrennung folgen dann
brauchen Sie auch nicht 16 Milliarden
Euro zu bezahlen für die Mehrkosten die
ausgelöst wurden durch die einheitliche
strompreiszone die Laufzeitverlängerung
löst keine Probleme sondern schafft neue
vielen Dank
sagt Ralf lenkert für die Linke so
nächster Redner wird sein Helmut
Kleebank für die SPD-Fraktion erst der
Vorsitzende des Beirates für nachhaltige
Entwicklung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit einigen
Monaten diskutieren wir den
Weiterbetrieb die Laufzeitverlängerung
der Atomkraftwerke ich will noch mal
kurz die Ursachen für diese Debatte
aufzählen es ist in erster Linie der
angriffskriegs Krieg Russlands auf die
Ukraine es ist mit Sicherheit ein
zweiter Stelle das ausbleibende Gas aus
Russland wohlgemerkt kein embargo
sondern das einseitige Abdrehen der
Gaslieferung durch Putin es ist der
fehlende Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien im Süden unserer Republik durch
die bayerische Landesregierung ebenso
wie quasi der Boykott des Netzausbaus
mindestens genauso wichtig wieder
fehlende Windkraftausbau und es ist
natürlich auch auch das wurde schon
gesagt
der Ausfall der Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich an dieser Stelle
International wurde hier gesprochen von
einer Renaissance der AKW wir hatten
gerade in der Anhörung einen
interessantes Ergebnis
international betrachtet ist gerade das
Gegenteil der Fall weil der
internationale Kraftwerkspark der AKW
schneller arbeiten schneller altert als
die Ausbaupläne der betreffenden Staaten
vorhanden sind das heißt es passiert de
facto ein schleichender Ausstieg aus der
Atomenergie statt einer Renaissance also
das komplette Gegenteil
positiv am vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf
ist aus meiner Sicht auf jeden Fall dass
es sich eben gerade nicht um eine
Notreserve handelt sondern es handelt
sich um einen regulären geregelten
absehbaren steuerbaren vorbereitbaren
streckbetrieb und eben nicht in
irgendeiner Konstellation gehen wir mal
schnell mit ein paar AKW ans Netz das
kann ich funktionieren insofern völlig
richtig dass wir das hier so machen
Ausgangspunkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen war der hier schon mehrfach
angesprochene zweite Stresstest und es
ist eben nicht so Herr lenkert dass
alles hundert Prozent gesichert ist
sondern der Test hat eindeutig ergeben
dass es ein gewisses wenn auch kleines
für ein paar Stunden mit einer gewissen
Leistung versehen des Risiko gibt und es
ist auch klar dass die Atomkraftwerke
die wir in den streckbetrieb geben
werden dieses Risiko leider nur zum Teil
auffangen werden also es ist ein Risiko
ich persönlich bin überzeugt dass es
nicht greifen wird weil eben unsere
anderen Maßnahmen auch zum Tragen kommen
der Preiseffekt über den geredet worden
ist auch das hat die Anhörung gegeben
ist ergeben ist höchst spekulativ die
Spannbreite die da berechnet worden ist
je nachdem welches Szenario angenommen
worden ist zeigt aber eines der
Preiseffekt den wir damit erzielen würde
nämlich insbesondere auch mit einem
Betrieb bis Ende 24 ist so gering dass
er weit hinter dem zurückbleibt was wir
eine entlastungspaketen geschnürt haben
weit hinter dem zurückbleibt was mit der
strompreisbremse erreicht würden wird
und insofern ist es völlig richtig
diesen Weg den sie vorschlagen nicht zu
gehen
es ist klar der streckbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke ist nur ein Baustein um
für eine Energiesicherheit in diesem
Winter zu kommen es sind einige Dinge
genannt ich will nur nennen die
Gasspeicher sind zu fast 100 Prozent
gefüllt übrigens der höchste Füllstand
in den letzten Jahren erreicht obwohl
Putin seinen Gashand zugedreht hat
wir werden weiter Gas einsparen die
Preissignale die Gesetz sind werden
trotz der Preis Bremsen erhalten bleiben
auch das ist ein wichtiger Punkt und zum
Jahresende werden die schwimmenden
lng-terminals am Netz sein und uns
unterstützen wir werden eben die Kraft
wärmekopplung bei den Gaskraftwerken
eben nicht abschalten können wir werden
weiterhin auch gasverstrom und das ist
ein wichtiges Signal wir haben eine
Fülle von Maßnahmen und wir werden in
diesem Winter Energie sicher sein
noch ein Wort zum längerfristigen
Weiterbetrieb den Sie vorschlagen ich
bin wirklich sehr erstaunt also bis 2024
ist da die Idee aber das Entscheidende
ist ja ihr Hintertürchen und dass man
muss man hier ganz klar benennen diese
prüfoption ist ein ganz klares
Hintertürchen und ich zählt jetzt mal
auf für den Ausstieg vom Ausstieg des
Ausstiegs aus dem Ausstieg also selten
so eine Kapriole gesehen die sie hier
schießen und die ist mit uns nicht zu
machen
noch ein Wort zum Thema Abhängigkeiten
Brennstäbe Brennelemente Uranförderung
wir würden uns auf diesem Weg in
dieselbe Abhängigkeit von Russland
begeben wie wir beim Gas in 50 Prozent
der weltweiten Förderung sind in
Russlands Hand entweder direkt oder
mittelbar das heißt dieses preisspiel
die Verunsicherung der Märkte die Putin
mit uns beim Gas gespielt hat kann er
könnte er würde er an dieser Stelle
wieder genauso spielen auch wenn die
Kondition ein klein wenig anders sind
ist mir bewusst aber wir dürfen an
dieser Stelle dieses Risiko auf keinen
Fall eingehen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ein Wort vielleicht noch nein kein Wort
mehr ich bitte um Zustimmung zu dem
Gesetzentwurf danke schön
wahrscheinlich weil die Redezeit
abgelaufen war Helmut Klebern war das
für die SPD-Fraktion ja er hat
angesprochen es gab heute durchaus
interessante
parlamentarische Beratung in den
Ausschüssen auch schon es gab eine
Expertenanhörung im Umweltausschuss zu
dem Thema und es gab heute morgen eine
öffentliche Sitzung des
Petitionsausschusses wo es um eine
Petition ging die sich für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung ausspricht also das
spielt natürlich heute hier in diese
Debatte auch immer wieder hinein Klaus
Wiener jetzt für die cdu/csu-fraktion
an aber der Preis dafür war hoch
gefrecktes Gas wurde teuer eingekauft
aber was noch viel schlimmer ist in dem
Zusammenhang sie haben
ärmeren Ländern das Gas auf den
Weltmärkten vor der Nase weggeschnappt
die Aufregung hierüber ist groß zu Recht
wenn man bedenkt was das für die
Menschen dort oftmals an existenzieller
not bedeutet
nicht minder groß nicht mindergroßes die
Aufregung darüber dass in der aktuellen
mangelage alte Kohlekraftwerke zum
Einsatz gebracht werden während die viel
klimafreundlichere alternative Atomstrom
von ihnen ausgeklammert wird bis ja bis
auf den kläglichen streckbetrieb über
den wir heute in erster Lesung beraten
viele aus ihrem Lager sagen immer wieder
gebetsmühlenartig das sei eine
hochrisikotechnologie darüber meine ich
lässt sich streiten zumindest wird das
im Ausland ganz überwiegend nicht so
gesehen und man findet den Begriff auch
gar nicht in der wissenschaftlichen
Literatur sicher ist aber sicher ist
aber das mit Blick auf das Klima eine
hoch das sie inzwischen eine
hochrisikopolitik betreiben und wenn sie
mir schon nicht glauben dann zitiere ich
hier nochmal an der Stelle Herrn
rockström vom Potsdam Institut für
Klimafolgenforschung am Wochenende in
der fast nachzulesen die Klimakrise ist
viel zu ernst und bestehende Kraftwerke
zu schließen nur sie wollen es einfach
nicht verstehen nur sie wollen es
einfach nicht verstehen der Einsatz der
tschuldigung Herr Dr Wiener gestatten
sie eine Zwischenbemerkung oder Frage
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
nein ich würde hier einfach weitermachen
der Einsatz der Kernkraftwerke würde im
Vergleich zu Strom aus Kohle die Mission
um jährlich 70 Millionen Tonnen CO2
verringern das muss man sich mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen 70 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 das sind knapp zehn Prozent
aller unsere Missionen oder 40 Prozent
der Emissionen die wir einsparen müssen
wenn wir die 2030er Ziele Pariser
Klimaziele einhalten wollen Deutschland
wird seine CO2-Ziele in den nächsten
Jahren krachend verfehlen und dafür
tragen sie die Verantwortung
jetzt höre ich sehr guter Hinweis Herr
Ebner sehr guter Hinweis jetzt höre ich
aus ihrem Lager immer wieder hätte
Deutschland die erneuerbaren Energien
stärker ausgebaut hätten wir das
Energieproblem nicht das ist das muss
man mal so deutlich sagen blanker Unsinn
zum einen weil Deutschland
zum einen weil Deutschland die
erneuerbaren Energien deutlich stärker
ausgebaut hat als fast alle anderen
Länder auf dieser Erde das habe ich hier
an dieser Stelle auch schon wieder rot
ausgeführt noch schlimmer aber ist dass
sie die Dimension des Problems verkennen
von 600 Terawatt Strom Stunden Strom die
wir jährlich bauen brauchen kommen 300
terrabattstunden aktuell aus den
Erneuerbaren das sind 50 Prozent ein
schöner Erfolg der letzten 16 Jahre über
den ich mich wirklich freue
unser jährlicher Energiebedarf beträgt
den toto aber nicht 600 Terawattstunden
sondern 3.400 Terawattstunden also mehr
als das 11-fache verstehen Sie mich
nicht falsch auch ich will dass die
Erneuerbaren ausgebaut werden und das
mit Tempo aber seien Sie doch endlich
mal ehrlich zu den Menschen ja das wird
Zeit brauchen viel Zeit und auch
entscheiterndes möglich ja weil
geldtechnologien Fachkräfte fehlen
deshalb wäre es klug vielleicht mal
zuhören deshalb wäre es klug alle
Energieformen so lange zu nutzen bis wir
wissen dass wir es geschafft haben und
nicht vorher abschalten in dieser
dramatischen Situationen beraten wir
heute in erster Lesung ein Atomgesetz
das ein Weiterbetrieb nur bis zum 15
April vorsieht aber nicht mit neuen
Brennstäben was sinnvoll wäre sondern im
dürftigen streckbetrieb ich habe es ja
schon gesagt und das auch nicht aus
tieferer Einsicht heraus
den Koalitionsfrieden
Recht vor allem Sommer mit dem
Umweltausschuss in Schweden Herr Ebner
sie waren ja auch dabei auch da will man
aus der Kernenergie aussteigen das macht
man aber mit einem gewissen Pragmatismus
nämlich man steigt erst da aus wenn die
Erneuerbaren hinreichend ausgebaut sind
das würde ich mir auch für Deutschland
wünschen aber das würde erfordern dass
sie einen klaren Plan haben wie wir die
Energiewende unter den dramatisch
geänderten Rahmenbedingungen tatsächlich
hinbekommen das liegt aber bislang
leider nicht vor und es würde erfordern
und es wird erfordern dass sie ihre
Verantwortung endlich gerecht werden und
wirklich alle Optionen auf den Tisch
bringen dazu gehört in der aktuellen
Krise eben auch ein Weiterbetrieb der
bestehenden Kernkraftwerke über den 15.4
hinaus kein Wiedereinstieg wohlgemerkt
aber schon so dass es für die Menschen
und die Unternehmen einen Unterschied
macht das ist in ihrem Gesetz nicht der
Fall und deswegen lehnen wir diesen
Gesetzentwurf auch ab vielen Dank
sagt Klaus Wiener für die
cdu/csu-fraktion aber heute wird ja noch
nicht abgestimmt erste Lesung und
deswegen geht jetzt nach Klaus Wiener
der war ja der letzte Redner für heute
dieser Gesetzentwurf in die Ausschüsse
gehören mal die Bundestagspräsidentin
Ordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen ich sehe keine weiteren
Vorschläge dann ist das so der Fall ab
Freitag wird es dann hier im Bundestag
in zweiter und dritter Lesung beraten
und mutmaßlich dann verabschiedet mit
den Stimmen der Ampelkoalition also mit
diesem mit dieser Änderung des
Atomgesetzes bleibt es bei der
Grundsatzentscheidung aus der
Kernenergie auszusteigen auch wenn die
drei verbliebenen AKWs dann bis Mitte
April 2023 laufen können bei Isa 2 zum
Beispiel wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
der Fall sein weil die Brennstäbe
voraussichtlich nur bis zum März reich